between the recently concluded sophomore
season of the mandalorian and the
long-awaited debut of maxwell lord in
wonder woman 1984
the world is experiencing a pedro pascal
boom
audiences of pascal fever their pascal
starved past the pascal the masses cry
out as one
pounding their fists on the table but
there's just not enough pascal to go
around
it's a past calamity get it
or at least it used to be before netflix
push forward the release date for we can
be heroes by a week
the family-friendly superhero flick
dropped on netflix
on december 25th and is now tearing up
the streaming service's top 10 most
watched list
doling out generous helpings of pedro
pascal as it goes
despite what its title and fresh cast
suggests we can be heroes is actually a
stand-alone sequel to 2005's the
adventures of sharkboy and lava girl in
3d
which centers around a young boy named
max escaping his real-life bullies by
jumping into a fantasy world
and imagining the super heroic antics of
well sharkboy and lava girl
chaos and adventure ensue when the two
heroes become real
and call upon max's help to save their
home world of planet draw
we can be heroes picked up 15 years
after the events of the first film
introducing a new generation of
superpower children with abilities
from across the comic book spectrum in
the film pascal played sword enthusiast
marcus moreno who's the leader of the
heroics this universe is justice league
avengers analog
when an alien invasion threatens the
world he and his fellow super folk are
called into action but a brief
altercation
sees them out matched by other worldly
forces with earth's greatest heroes held
captive
and alien invaders threatening to
destroy the planet it's up to the hero's
children to save the day
pascal performing in the second robert
rodriguez joins this year
following the mandalorians chapter 14
the tragedy isn't the only familiar face
in the group boyd holbrook probably best
known for playing the leader of the
reverse in 2017's logan
plays miracle guy the requisite superman
standing
christian slater plays techno the team's
gadget guy
and taylor dooley returns to her role as
lava girl after a 15-year absence
at the kids table there's yaya goslin of
usa networks the purge series
playing pascal's daughter the seemingly
non-superpowered missy moreno
who leads a cast of relative newcomers
as they stretch
fly and super strength their way through
a vibrant adventure story
written and directed by robert rodriguez
we can be heroes has all the earmarks of
the filmmaker's distinctive brand of
kids entertainment
the bright colors and chroma key set
pieces are out in force
creating a bombastic world that looks
like it's made out of play-doh and gak
it's packed from top to bottom with
action features plenty of comedic
moments
that both kids and adults can enjoy and
perhaps best of all for
everyone watching sends a strong message
about inclusion and teamwork
if you're anywhere past your pre-teen
years we can be heroes isn't going to
blow your mind in the way a superhero
movie like the captain america
spider-man or avengers franchises would
but it will entertain you for the
duration of its run time
despite being angled toward a younger
audience plus if you have youngsters of
your own it's a great film to stream
over the holiday break
reviews for we can be heroes have
trended positive and rotten tomatoes
it touts a 67 approval rating from
critics the general consensus points to
a bright family oriented story
with fun set pieces fast pacing and
silly light-hearted comedy
and individual critics reviews put the
spotlight and we can be heroes many
charms the chicago sun times critic
richard roper
wrote in his review of the film we can
be heroes has the vibe of a saturday
morning live-action serial
only with better special effects though
aimed at a young audience
this is one of those superhero
adventures that will keep the adults
entertained as well
heroes is actually the kind of movie
that works just fine on the home screen
it's a perfectly serviceable 90-minute
diversion and we can't have too many
entertaining diversions these days
writing for rogerebert.com carlos aguila
had similarly kind things to say about
we can be heroes
saying on the scale of how solemnly
movies take the extraordinary protectors
of the earth we can be heroes places
somewhere between disney sky high
and marvel's the avengers but boasts a
distinct candy-coloured futurism of
rodriguez's pg-rated earth
rodriguez pokes fun at the trity tropes
and delivers on the action
often also lacing the fights with humor
but always with an earnest
message on how adults set in their
southern ways don't always know best
with enough enjoyable originality to
differentiate it from the numerous takes
on the supermen
and wonder women that so heavily
populate film and tv these days
we can be heroes flies rodriguez back to
one of his main areas of interest
essentially we can be heroes as
everything audiences have come to expect
from a robert rodriguez children's film
plus lest we forget it's got pedro
pascal center stage
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one